[Musique]
vivre cachés en exil ce n'était pas
l'avis qu'elle un stade ias et amir
envisagée à 33 et 34 ans il est avocat
elle est entrepreneur un jeune couple
rend plus d'espoir et de projets pour
leur pays
le bélarus s'est aujourd'hui de leur
petit appartement en lituanie le pays
voisin et qu'il suivait regarde
stupéfait leurs confrères tenir tête à
un régime sans scrupules passe
tous les deux se considère chanceux
chanceux d'être en vie ensemble et en
sécurité car la nuit du 11 ou dernier
ils ont cru que c'était la fin
anastasia et amir était à 500 mètres de
leur appartement en voiture avec des
médecins bénévoles
quand ils ont aperçu des manifestants
plaqué au sol et se sont arrêtés pour
les aider face du coup de poing au
visage avant d'être embarqué avec 5
entre autres personnes pour la prison de
christina où ces images ont été captées
et nice anastasia dit que les femmes ont
été regroupés dans des cages à
l'extérieur fouillée à nu dans les
cavités humilié et puis battu à leur
tour
[Musique]
we just dix heures d'angoissé durant
lesquelles leurs bourreaux les ont
prévenus du prix qu'ils allaient payer
pour leur opposition président
lukashenko goûtu notre soif de 50 euros
ces photos du corps damiron été prise
trois jours plus tard quand il a été
libéré parce que la prison était rempli
à pleine capacité et son histoire et
celle de centaines d'autres bélarus qui
ont porté plainte pour torture
une brutalité y compris des viols
documenté par l'organisme human rights
watch
bien que régime continue à nier avec des
reportages comme celui ci est la
télévision d'état qui offre une visite
de la même prison toute personne les
torturer explique un gardien amériain
nastasia ont peur de rentrer tant et
aussi longtemps que loukachenko sera
président on les a même menacé de les
arrêter à nouveau et de leur faire pire
s'ils ont le malheur de ce mini
manifestation qui continue malgré la
répression
non
nous continuerons à positionner posture
[Musique]
oui à notre position car nous ne sommes
plus l'opposition va venir regarder
regardez dans la rue nous sommes
maintenant la majorité